President Trump is sharply escalating
the trade dispute with China putting US
consumers in line to pay higher prices
for thousands of products the president
rallied with supporters in Cincinnati
last night after threatening a new round
of tariffs they would add ten percent to
the cost of another 300 billion dollars
a year of Chinese goods the new threat
led to big losses on Wall Street
yesterday Ben Tracy is at the White
House then how are the Chinese
responding to this well overnight
China's foreign ministry says that if
the president does go through these new
tariffs that China will retaliate and
that would likely mean higher tariffs on
American products now at his rally in
Ohio the president said he's going to
quote tax the hell out of China but he
did save his harshest rhetoric four
Democrats will never be a socialist
country never ever ever will it be a
socialist country the president is in
full campaign mode calling Democrats
socialists who want to destroy the
country Democrat lawmakers care more
about illegal aliens then they care
about their own constituents a protester
with a sign that said immigrants built
America
caused the president to pause his speech
for nearly five minutes in interruption
he then blamed on a Democrat Cincinnati
do you have a Democrat mayor
well that's what happens the president
offered a scathing takedown of major
American cities the homicide rate in
Baltimore is significantly higher than
El Salvador Honduras look at Los Angeles
with the tents and the horrible horrible
disgusting conditions Ohio is considered
essential to the president's reelection
thank you Ohio
we love you Ohio in 2016 he beat Hillary
Clinton there by 8 points but in a
recent poll President Trump currently
trails Joe Biden in the state by 8
points
we are finally putting America first and
while American consumers are footing the
bill for the tariffs already in place in
the ongoing trade war the president once
again claimed otherwise you're not
paying for those tariffs China's paying
for those tariffs mr. Trump says China
might be dragging its feet on a trade
deal in the hopes of a new negotiator
they'd say this sleepy Joe sure just
sign right there ok outside President
Trump says these new tariffs will go
into effect on September 1st
if that happens it basically means there
is a tax on everything that China sends
to the US that's everything from
t-shirts and tennis shoes to iPads and
iPods and there are no new trade talks
scheduled until after September 1st
she'll see what the fallout is thank you
and Tracy